Ai In 2041 big cybernetic luck.
Hello world.
It's Saroj.
And what does Ai Look like in 2040 it's
really hard to make predictions about
the field five years from now,
let alone 20 years from now because
there are so many unknown variables.
But amidst all the current fear
around automation, technology,
taking away jobs from humans,
manipulating our attention via social
networks and someday even destroying us.
Yo Ilan,
please make rockets not fear.
I thought it would be important for
me to give an optimistic vision of the
future of AI backed by my knowledge
of various current research efforts.
The predictions I'll make in this
episode are split into three parts. Ai,
hardware, AI, software, and
Ai's effects on society.
So let's start with AI hardware.
Pretty much every conventional computer
and smart device available today is
based on some variation of what's
called a von Neumann architecture,
which was first proposed in 1945 by the
original gangsters slash mathematician
John von Neumann.
It divides the hardware of a computer
into three main components, memory,
a central processing unit or
CPU and input output devices.
So the input could be say a mouse or
keyboard while the output could be a
monitor. The CPU is in charge of fetching
instructions and data from memory,
executing those instructions. Then storing
the resulting values back in memory.
And the great thing about the
CPU is that it's flexible.
We can use it for any kind of software
from word processing to automatically
blocking all videos of
metallic rapid make it stop.
But despite its flexibility,
CPS execute operations sequentially and
have to access memory every time they
do,
which limits data throughput.
And this is called the von Neumann
bottleneck to gain higher data throughput.
And many computers use a
graphics processing unit or GPU.
Modern Gpu usually have thousands of
arithmetic logic unit in a processor,
which means they can execute thousands
of operations in parallel AI algorithms
like neural networks demand massive
parallelism to execute millions of
operations. So the GPU has been the
primary driver of their recent successes.
There's also the recently introduced
TPU use that Google designed that aren't
general purpose there. Instead
designed to do one task really well,
parallel matrix operations.
And because of that,
they're able to reduce the von
Neumann bottleneck even more than gps.
Notice the trend here. Of course you do.
Eugenia, you're so smart. I love you.
We are building computers
that are increasingly parallel
and require less energy
and they're currently exists.
Another processor that uses much
less energy and has a throughput,
no TPU can match and it exists in
our heads. It's the human brain.
The field of neuromorphic computing
currently being researched by several tech
companies like Intel aims to emulate
this natural processing architecture of
ours.
Neuromorphic chips are inspired by
biological neural networks where logic and
memory are closely integrated
in the same basic device,
the neurons and their connections.
The problem with current
system architectures is
that data and processing are
physically separated and
continuous signals are
represented using binary states.
How are we supposed to make sex
robots if that's the case? Jeez.
The solution is to use
components called memory stirs,
which like normal resistors regulate
the flow of electricity that can
additionally remember a particular charge
allowing them to act like synapses in
the brain.
They can process and store multiple or
even continuous signal states orders of
magnitudes faster and with much
less power than current systems.
There are various different ideas on what
to use as a memory stir from graphing
nanostructures to opto electronics,
but eventually prediction time or you
single celled organisms as living memory
stirs.
A few years ago,
a team of bio engineers from Stanford
announced that they created a fully
functional computer from living material.
They used protein to store bits and
molecular motors called Maslan to move
protein filaments along artificial
paths to eventually solve a simple
mathematical problem.
Based on the optimal path,
our computers will eventually be made up
a fully organic living material that's
been engineered to replicate
our biological neural
network will use DNA to store
data.
A single gram of DNA is capable
of storing 215 petabytes of data,
which could store every bit of data ever
recorded by humans in a container the
size and weight of one room and scientists
have already started storing digital
data in Dna since 2012 sic a fortune
500 company is already developing neural
networks from living nerve cell tissue.
The future of computing is biological.
We'll eventually build a fully
integrated living biological computer,
which functions independently of its
creators and replicates on its own like I
prop eight
and the primary way we'll
use this technology is by
incorporating it into a mind
body machine interface.
Very similar to the noninvasive device I
designed in a previous video called the
link, the Mbmi. We'll replace all of
our other devices including smartphones.
It will be able to read and write to
the brain which will allow us to know
everything, be everywhere and do
practically anything we'd like.
But before I shock you by explaining
the mechanism it will use to communicate
with the Internet,
I need to give you a short primer
on quantum mechanics for context.
Last year,
D-Wave,
the quantum computing company invited me
to their facility to see their quantum
computer and meet their team.
The discussions I had with those quantum
scientists inspired me to learn a lot
more about quantum mechanics of field.
I didn't pay too much attention to
before and the more I learn about quantum
mechanics,
the more skeptical I am about our
current understanding of the nature of
reality.
There is no spoon.
Currently we have two
major theories of physics,
quantum mechanics and general relativity
at the smallest scales of reality.
Quantum mechanics helps explain
a lot and at the largest scales,
general relativity explains a lot,
but we don't have a theory of everything
and equation or set of equations that
would connect quantum mechanics
to general relativity.
It could in fact be the case that all
living things are connected through
quantum entanglement.
That consciousness not
matter is fundamental to the
universe and that the brain
performs at some form of quantum
computation. Nobody knows.
As such.
In 2040 we'll leverage some mechanism
of quantum mechanics that we haven't yet
fully understood like quantum entanglement
to connect with other people and the
Internet of things.
And this will form a new quantum internet.
Wild quantum entanglement hasn't yet
proven to allow for faster than light data
transfer.
I predict that our understanding of the
nature of reality will gradually evolve
and we'll find a way that means
zero latency communication
with other humans via
quantum entanglement.
Forget about Bluetooth and Wifi and in
a similar vein to how Tesla envision a
world where electricity was transmitted
via wireless towers all around the earth
will transmit energy wirelessly
through quantum energy teleportation.
A concept a Japanese physicist
demonstrated a few years ago now onto AI
software.
It's currently 2019 and the deep learning
revolution has made a massive impact
on the field. There are three
core properties to deep learning.
Then make it so powerful.
The first is generality.
We have a small number of deep learning
tools and they solve a huge array of
problems.
The second piece is competence.
If you want to solve some
image related problem,
just throw out 30 years of computer
vision research and replace it with a deep
neural network.
And the third piece is scalability.
If you have a neural network and
feed it more data and compute,
it will get better and better.
These three properties feel like
essential parts of building a general
intelligence.
There are clearly missing pieces though
we need an answer for causal reasoning,
but for the first time we have a
paradigm that gives us hope that general
intelligence can be achievable.
So the question is how
will we improve on it?
Sprinkled quantum audits in a new nature
paper titled supervised learning with
Quantum enhanced features spaces the
authors describe developing a quantum
algorithm that could
perform feature mapping,
a key component in machine learning on
high dimensional data at a scale far
beyond the reach of even the most
powerful classical computers,
quantum computing techniques and more
powerful processors hold the key to
enabling machines to have causal reasoning
and we'll add these capabilities to
future organic neuromorphic computers,
future neural optimization strategies.
We'll leverage quantum mechanics and
organic material to solve problems and
evolutionary computing techniques will
finally start to work well also will
program with our mind.
We won't have to write code anymore
and thankfully that includes PHP.
We'll use these optimization algorithms
to create more software like incredibly
sophisticated encryption schemes and
different types of internet architectures.
The Internet will be like a grid, a
self organizing, intelligent network,
distributed ledger technology
currently enables a primitive form of
decentralized decision making right now.
It allows payments to be made across
the Internet without middlemen,
but in 20 years that
technology will have evolved.
Eventually all apps we know of like Uber,
airbnb and porn hub will be run at the
protocol level in a fully automated way
with AI at the center
and humans at the edges.
These will be autonomous self improving
services that interconnect and connect
to other services as per
their objective functions.
And the question as to where you host
your files or what service you use to book
a self driving car will be irrelevant.
You'll use the internet to do so.
Names of service has become irrelevant.
The Internet will truly become
a collective consciousness
and each of us will
store a personal AI assistant locally in
our MBM eyes that will act in our best
interest. Helping us parse data and
communicate fake news won't be an issue.
We'll be smart enough through our MBM
eyes to be able to perform quantum proofs
of reality to detect what's real.
And what's fake now onto how
this will affect society.
Our Ai's will be conscious.
There'll be able to love, feel pain,
and experience the world in the same ways
that we do just without a natural body.
We will coexist in this world with these
engineered minds flowing into and out
of states of unified consciousness
with them falling in love with them,
having debates with them and
enjoying life together. Ultimately,
this world of super intelligent beings,
both human born and machine born will
result in a new renaissance for humanity.
Unlike anything we've ever seen before.
These digital beings will be
able to do anything we can do,
including creativity and discovery.
That means we'll automate away
almost every job that exists today,
not just truck drivers and retail workers,
which are currently being automated
away, but lawyers, doctors,
and even science vikings.
So what do we do? Well,
first we'll all receive a universal basic
income that comes from the Internet,
a machine generated dividend that rewards
us for the gains in efficiency from
automating manual labor.
This will remove the necessity
to work to live on top of that.
All sorts of meaningful jobs will
exist that never existed today.
Things we wouldn't even
think of as jobs like gaming,
matchmaking for Ais and humans
evangelizing newly engineered flavors,
tasting and writing, different
types of foods, traveling the world,
collecting data, learning
and volunteering, and
because we'll have MBM eyes,
our ability to learn,
make discoveries and perform artistic
expressions will be just as scalable as
any AI and because of basic income,
self driving cars and full
immersion virtual reality,
we'll see a reverse migration of people
from cities to newly formed villages
that live in harmony with the land.
No one will have a nine to five job
they need to commute to anymore.
The world will become one big village
with people constantly traveling between
what we now consider countries since MBM
eyes will let us speak and understand
every language and in a world of abundance
where all of our basic needs are met
through basic income,
where technology makes us smarter,
more aware and better able to
communicate with other humans.
I believe that we'll all as a result
become kinder than ever before,
and I think that's a future
worth looking forward to.
And what do you think AI
will look like in 20 years?
Let me know in the comment section and
please subscribe for more technology
videos for now. I've got to
meditate, so thanks for watching.